Speaker 1: There are sort of like some
obscure anti-vax people that have died during the
pandemic. You know, I'll mention to you, Oh, this,
you know, Deputy County Commissioner, I don't
even remember what she was in California,
who went to an anti-vax rally and posted some
anti-vax stuff on her Facebook. She now died of
COVID, but typically most of those folks are not
like known to us. And when they're known to us,
they're often not known as anti-vax people. There
is an incredible news story which dozens of you
sent me over the weekend about a
Washington state police officer
who was sort of a celebrity anti-vaxxer. This
was not an obscure random officer. Robert LeMay
quit his job as a Washington state trooper
because he didn't want to get vaccinated
during his signoff, which we will look at. He
told the governor, Jay Inslee, to kiss his ass.
He was on Fox News being interviewed by
Laura Ingraham as if he was some kind of hero
for quitting over the vaccine mandate. He's dead
of COVID. He's dead of Kovac, state trooper who
told governor to kiss my ass over vaccine mandate
dies of COVID 19. This is from two days ago.
Robert LeMay, 51, famously signed off in his
squad car after 22 years of service in October,
just a few months ago, while blasting Democratic
Gov. Jay Inslee. The governor had mandated state
workers get vaccinated against COVID, not unique
to the state of Washington. LeMay died on Friday.
Here is his principled and defiant
signoff, where he also sends a shot
across the bow at the governor, Jay Inslee.
Speaker 2: Wish I could say more, but
this is it so. State Sen 34. This
is the last time you hear me in a
state of shock and James, you can kiss my ass.
Speaker 1: Wow. What a principled and defiant
action that this guy took once again. He was
also known to the Fox News community. Here he is,
being interviewed by Laura Ingraham and
getting a hero's welcome. This was in October,
right around the time that he did this stunt.
Speaker 2: Well, last time I checked, they weren't
really worried about the vaccination status at
the border when we had now tens of thousands
of people waved in and want a two week period, so
they don't seem too concerned about that, Robert.
What's next for you? Other than being a
celebrity now, what's next for you? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Other than catching
COVID and dying, right?
Speaker 2: You know, I'm overwhelmed. I
really am. I'm a pretty private person
and my son's in the military. I'm like saying,
this is what's happening. He goes, All right,
dad, I'm going black. So it's we're just trying to
put our feet on the ground and it's funny. We were
very religious people and we prayed
about all this when it first started.
You know, Lord, what do you want us to do?
Speaker 1: And notice that the prayer did not save
him from COVID. And that's the again is did he
not pray correctly? Did he not pray hard enough?
Did he do other things wrong so that God
did not answer his prayers? Because for
all the prayer he died of COVID,
Speaker 2: it's our path and we've
applications out of state and all types of stuff.
But Lord never really pointed us to one point, so
we said, OK, maybe this is the fight. Well, then
that came out and it went viral, and I'm like,
OK, this is where you want us to do right now. So
I'm the spokesperson for thousands and thousands.
I even say millions of people. I think there's two
million people that have actually viewed it. It's
been ninety nine percent positive from everybody.
I think this is my path right now. There's a lot
of job offers and I'm getting phenomenal
job offers. All right. Well, I'm a sleeping
giant now. We're maybe asleep, a sleeping giant.
Speaker 1: All right. So and there. Laura Ingraham
cuts him off. She's had enough of it. So what
was next for Robert LeMay was catching COVID on
vaccinated and dying. And of course, as I've said
before, we can't say for sure about any individual
he would have survived had he been vaccinated. We
can't. You can't ever say that about a particular
person, statistically, because the vaccines are so
effective at preventing serious illness and death,
all those great job offers that he was getting all
of this celebrity welcome and all of that he would
have been able to carry it out had he just been
vaccinated. But of course, had he been vaccinated,
he never would have become the anti-vax hero in
the first place. The takeaway here, guys, is this
is a cautionary tale. We're not dancing on his
grave. The cautionary tale is no matter how brazen
your rhetoric is, no matter how alpha you believe
yourself or others believe you to be because of
your job or because of your physical appearance
or whatever, COVID might kill you. And so we have
one tool that really reduces the odds of that.
And it's the vaccine this guy chose to forgo it.
It was because of his prayer to God, not because
of any valid medical reason or anything else. He
has now died of COVID celebrity anti-vax cop
who told Jay Inslee to kiss his ass is dead
and he will not be working any of those other
jobs. We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman show is primarily funded by
viewers and listeners like you who sign up on our
website. Join Packman dot com. We do an
extra show every day for our members and I
would love for you to sign up. You can use
the coupon code 222 to get a sizable discount
and you'll become a member instantly. You can
once again do that at join Packman dot com